So what makes anxiety healthy?
Anxiety is healthy when it is
serving as an alarm system
that lets us know that something's not right,
that it gets ourattention and
helps us to keep ourselves safe.
The only time we consider anxiety to
cross the linefrom healthy to unhealthy
is under two conditions, actually.
One is when we have anxiety,
but there’sno threat,
that there's nothing wrong.
So if it's, you know, a lovely Sunday
morning and you'retaking a drive
and there's no traffic nearby,
you shouldn't be having an
anxiety response inthat moment.
And if you do, we would consider
that grounds for concern.
The other time wepay attention to
anxiety and consider it to be unhealthy
is if the anxiety response is way
too big for what's happened,
out of proportion to events.
So if somebody swerves and cut you off
and you have a panic attack in that moment,
that is not healthy anxiety,
it is not helping you.
Andwe would address that clinically.
Other than that, we really see anxiety
as largely normal,protective, healthy
and useful in our lives.